John Wick's world keeps getting grander
and the stakes keep getting higher
before you head to the theater to watch
John Wick chapter 4 you'd better learn
all you can about the Assassin and is
war with the high table the release date
for the fourth John Wick Future Has
Changed multiple times for several
different reasons it was originally
announced during the opening week of
John Wick chapter 3 Parabellum that the
fourth outing of the Baba Yaga would
drop in cinemas on May 22nd 2021 but due
to the covid-19 pandemic and Keanu
Reeves's obligations to The Matrix
resurrections the film was delayed until
May 27 2022. then in December 2021 the
pandemic caused another delay this time
to March 24th 2023. this move might very
well have been a blessing in disguise as
the May 27 2022 date would have put the
movie up against top gun Maverick which
was a massive success raking in over 1
billion dollars at the box office
Lionsgate announced the new date in a
video on YouTube featuring the
accountant the ladies that worked the
switchboards and rotary phones in the
John Wick franchise these tattooed
workers with sleeveless pink shirts are
in charge of sending out messages to the
many killers within the mysterious
networks database regarding which
unfortunate soul has a price on their
head the new date can be seen on the
chalkboard and old school computer
monitor the entire Affair caps things
off with the message be seeing you fans
can confidently mark their calendars as
John Wick chapter 4 will finally arrive
in theaters on March 24th 2023 and when
it does arrive it will be the longest
film in the franchise with collider
reporting it'll clock in at two and a
half hours last words Winston just have
fun out there it looks like John Wick
will take the war to the high table in
the fourth installment of the franchise
after growing tired of being the one on
the run from swarms of bloodthirsty
death dealers John will be looking to do
what he does best against the mysterious
leaders of the strange assassin-filled
underworld as the official plots and
offices tells us he'll travel from New
York to Paris to Osaka to Berlin in his
quest for vengeance and part of his plan
will be challenging a shadowy marquee to
a duel to the death if he wins or loses
either way he'll be free from the high
table director Chad stachowski talked
about the fourth film in the franchise
in an interview with Indie wire and
hinted at how things could turn out for
the titular character Jon May survive
all this but at the end of it there's no
happy ending he's got nowhere to go he's
for the rest of his life it's just a
matter of time he also told Empire that
the film will be more epic than the
previous movies we'll focus on multiple
story lines and said it will feel like a
combination of Greek myth Japanese
movies about the blind Samurai Satoshi
and The Good the Bad and the Ugly
whatever happens in John Wick chapter 4
fans can rest assured that there will be
plenty of action with stahlski promising
it will outdo its predecessors regarding
the franchise's bloodiest entry Keanu
Reeves will be back as the titular
unkillable killer in John Wick chapter 4
and he'll be accompanied by a stacked
roster full of talent familiar returning
faces include Ian McShane as the silver
tongued Winston and Lance Reddick as the
stoic Continental concierge Sharon
Lawrence Fishburn is back as the Bowery
King and these fan favorites will be
accompanied by a slew of newcomers
played by some pretty big names hit star
Bill Skarsgard is taking on the role of
the Marquis a character director Chad
stachelski is described as the one in
charge of cleaning up all the messes
from the first three movies then there's
legendary action star Donnie Yen
bringing his skills to the franchise is
King a blind martial artist and
ex-assassin who lost his eyesight to
protect his daughter he also seems to
have a complicated relationship with
Wick as he's been described as his
friend but will also battle our
dog-loving hero of course Yen isn't the
only martial arts star on board we've
also got Scott Adkins a films like
accident man playing a character named
Killa we've also got hiroyuki as shimazu
who fans will no doubt recognize from
Japanese movies like the Twilight
Samurai and ring as well as American
films like Mortal Kombat and bullet
train he'll be joined by Singer model
Rina sawyama making her cinematic debut
as Akira samayama is evidently pretty
psyched about the film telling enemy
that the fourth flick is 100 the best
John Wick that's ever been and I'm not
being biased like honestly the skill is
insane this time Shamir Anderson from
invasion is also joining the John Wick
fold as the tracker who's tahelski
describes as a character that's in the
gray area between the two worlds the
wick world and the real world and in
true John Wick fashion the tracker seems
to be a big fan of dogs plus character
actor extraordinaire Clancy Brown with
credits ranging from the Shawshank
Redemption to SpongeBob's SquarePants
will be bringing his gravitas to the
role of the harbinger and Natalie Tena
of Harry Potter Fame will be playing a
woman described by sahelski as someone
who's like like John's stepsister Chad
stalski has been a stuntman in the
industry for many years even doubling
for Brandon Lee on the crow stahlski
later worked with Keanu Reeves as a stud
coordinator on The Matrix movies but his
directorial debut came with John Wick in
2014 and he helmed the two sequels John
Wick chapter 2 and John Wick chapter 3
Parabellum it's pretty safe to assume
that his work with the John Wick
franchise is his biggest claim to fame
and he triumphantly returns to the
director's chair for John Wick chapter
4. stahlski has come a long way
throughout his career and there is no
denying he's found great success with
the John Wick movies he discussed his
thoughts with The Hollywood Reporter on
the fourth feature and how his
experiences have contributed to its
quality so I just tried to put all the
things I've gotten better at in the last
two and a half years into this movie I
hope that will make the movie better
instead of just trying to do bigger
explosions and bigger if I tell a better
story which I think I've done and do my
job a little bit better in every Avenue
I think the movie will be better after
the initial sneak peek dropped in July
2022 fans were treated to a full-length
trailer in November promising a film
that seems both emotional and
action-packed death revenge and the
possibility of redemption hang over the
trailer and going to die
maybe not and after that opening scene
we learned Jon as a way of escaping the
high tables wrath according to Ian
mcshane's Winston he can challenge Bill
skarsgard's Marquee to a duel if he wins
he's free if he dies well that's kind of
a freedom too we're then given a glimpse
of Natalia tennis character someone
who's said to be like Jon's stepsister
so we're assuming she has some sort of
connection to the underworld's most
powerful figures we're also excited to
witness all the incredible action on
display there's an epic staircase
shootout and angry attack dog John
chasing people through the desert on
Horseback and not one but two vicious
duels with Donnie Yen one where he's
having a sword fight with hiroyuki
Sonata and one where it's a katana and
Pistol battle with John Wick with each
new John Wick movie the scope and Stakes
get bigger and we learn more about the
Mysterious World of criminals and
assassins that means John Wick will be
doing some sightseeing in chapter 4 and
he'll drop by some pretty impressive
landmarks when speaking with collider
director Chad sahelski explained how
they shot scenes near the Eiffel Tower
and the Arctic Triomphe they even got to
film a scene inside the Louvre but don't
expect any crazy fights amongst all the
artwork even a great filmmaker like
stahlski has his limits when it comes to
getting approval to shoot explosive
action scenes in classy locations
speaking of cool action scenes it looks
like chapter 4 will really be upping the
ante when it comes to car chases we've
seen Jon burn some serious rubber in the
past but according to Keanu Reeves the
streets are about to get even more
intense speaking with total film the
actor said we took the car driving to
the next level which I really enjoy
there's 180s forward into reverse 180s
reverse into forward 270s drifting so it
was really fun to get a chance to learn
those skills and to play John Wick
chapter 4 is our Opus oh my God it's
crazy man it's banana cakes nobody
expected John Wick to become an
Unstoppable franchise now it's given
birth to a total of four films the
upcoming Continental prequel series and
the much anticipated ballerina spin-off
but will there be a proper fifth film
coming down the pipeline well according
to Total film chapter 4 and chapter 5
were originally supposed to film back to
back however the movie business is ever
changing and that didn't pan out but
chances are pretty good we'll see Jon
back in action man has to look his best
when it's time to get married
or buried director Chad sahelski implied
he'd be returning to the franchise after
directing Michael B Jordan in the
upcoming action thriller Rainbow Six he
told total film you might have to give
me and John Wick just a little break ask
me in a couple of months as for Reeves
The Humble star has this to say about a
potential fifth film you have to see how
the audience responds to what we did the
only reason we've had a chance to make
these movies is that people have liked
what we have done so I think we have to
wait and see how the audience responds
to it hopefully they'll like it in the
meantime you can expect to see the
titular hero going toe-to-toe with Anna
De armas as the two will share a fight
scene in the spin-off flick ballerina
[Music]